hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie dupois
Katie and I are gonna watch Conan and
Sona
I believe that's as a assistant as
Armenian assistant visit an Armenian
marketplace hey bro we're going to go to
a market place bro like July BMW and
smoke hookah bro haha stereotypes
stereotypes every Glendale Armenian
Chevy my therapist is Armenian she rocks
in basic G boo boo then you get to them
get it
to you yeah hey that's a deal
how would he remember mine this is the
marketplace and you're a bond ji guru
mmmm Johnny
it looks like a little bundle of some
sort of twig glad you're here okay tell
him we wish to buy dried apricots for
your family back home
even that eiki-sama you know you're not
really minding the store let people like
me do whatever they want what we're
getting is the apricot who are looking
for a beautiful this I know this is my
food this is the food of my people
yeah
Armenian viagra yeah my god right I'm
feeling things I haven't felt in years
I was talking more yeah it's like viagra
you a local creep huh thank you very
much hey in an hour I won't be able to
hug you
every day election
I'm so short yeah
oh so cute I really do love Conan
O'Brien I got to tell you guys when I
was growing up seventh and eighth grade
is when I discovered Conan Late Night
with Conan O'Brien cuz my dad liked to
watch the Leno Show [ __ ] he liked to
watch Jay Leno and then Conan randomly
came on and I was like a really sad dude
back then granted I want funniest kid in
junior high but that's besides the point
I masked it all my hilarious humor with
you know I messed the depression thank
you yeah you're probably frame that I
was waving chasers I found Conan and I
was just cracking up so late at night I
remember the first time I realized I
really loved Conan we had one working TV
my brother was like hey we just want a
eet on DVD let's watch this they waited
for Jay Leno to finish it popped on et
and I was like guys I want to watch
Conan but they didn't care they wanted
to watch et again but with better
quality when Conan had a brand new
episode on to this day I don't know what
episode that was that I missed I
realized a lot of my humor came from him
like wanting to perform to an audience
and kind of like the sarcastic miss the
satire the self was it called the bot
what's not self deprecation self to
butcher so fabricating humor so in
school I would say um yeah when I'm
feeling down I watch Conan O'Brien I
would call it my combs own medication
that's so dorky that's what it was oh
wow not like the scene like every
interview that's ever been released at
me my god I love Conan you should get a
shirt with just the orange hair isn't
what I wanted to be him once for
Halloween I always imagined if I went on
to his show
I would like dye my hair and just look
exactly like like it comes in all out
yeah we all go and do the string dance
bring some potatoes with you bring see a
because he loves the irish jokes I got
my Arnold impression from dollars on dah
dah dah
there's no actual words and that's where
I got my like cuz I noticed a lot of ISM
fresh like I picked up stuff
subconsciously like this is impressions
are a lot of times are just noises like
my new my stove owners know so this is
little dude
dude it's just like yeah you're not
actually saying yeah I'm not actually
saying something okay what's your master
impression impression my Cady impression
I come across appropriate but really I
have a dirty mind oh yeah right I like
to be a little mysterious unsettled the
quirky that's great that's what I put on
my you know my business cards shuttle
Mukherjee I like that he gives people
crap you know no one's off limits he's
in this Armenian market making fun of
Armenians within Armenians
is great one thing I noticed that I kind
of picked up on too is that when he
makes fun of power position like he
pretends like he's like so powerful oh
sure but but he's not any enough so I
like how he messes with his employees a
lot as if he's like this dictator but
everyone knows he's just clowning around
if I ever become famous not if but when
I become famous is you know to do more
charitable work but also could be to go
in charin oh right
I thought to you like I'm in the
audience I'll be like hey a lot of you
are visiting you ever been to like in a
nap even though it's not like only a
California thing but I'm into in-and-out
people be like now that I'm like weird
I'm taking the whole audience in and out
and then I'll be like in cones gonna
bring camera troupe the cones like we
didn't agree to that and then I'll be
like yeah but now we're on TV
you got it agree to it and then we take
a camera crew out go ahead and out
interact with fans it's very detailed ya
know I really in the internet you know
when they spawn you never imagine being
on the talk show never done that like
thing in real time gosh I guess I have
yeah oh I haven't done Jimmy Fallon yet
in my mind I should I should watch more
Jimmy Fallon NSYNC mind specific I think
I just worry about the things they would
like mine was combo it would be fun to
be on one of those games
I'm one of the celebrity what the [ __ ]
away if you were doing like a talk show
if it was one of the shows where you can
do games like Fallon does games yeah
yeah you know competitions I feel like
that would be fun okay that's fair good
point that'd be fun I know I said that's
fair so I was debating with you about it
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel hey guess what if you're new and
haven't subscribed yet why haven't you
click this button become a reject
[ __ ] I just don't feel good when I say
that because not because like Oh rejects
a bad word you've seen extras no Ricky
Gervais ends up getting this catchphrase
that he really didn't want to become a
catchphrase because he thinks they're
like cheaping stupid when I say become a
rejection I'm like Mike yup
catchphrase like it just sounds so like
if I name the audience something how
about on the news yeah okay little on
the note but I notice every youtuber
does it so now I got to do it
Katie du Bois has a facebook Instagram
maybe of some facial do something with
her YouTube channel who knows and soon
soon there's a show where she
guest-starred in three of the episodes
me you him just launched it's on YouTube
you can go check it out it's primarily a
black cast I'm trying to get at least
one or two of them on the channel I have
nothing against bringing three black
folks on just one or two just to
introduce some guests who knows maybe I
like all how come when I talk about
black people I just immediately come
across racist that's like my worry is
don't sound racist and then I end up
saying things that make me sound racist
yeah anyway yeah me you him check it out
link in description box